[Music]  i don't know what he's talking he keeps  talking about a race like what is he  racing to is it like a straight race  so some observations about the video he  looks very young like he looks too young  to be like waving around a gun  talking about how he's trying to beat a  case like  you seem kind of too young for that  honestly  observation number two there's some sort  of race going on i'm thinking like it  could be some sort of street race  but maybe that's like what the race oh  maybe it's because  he's racing to beat the case like it's a  race because he doesn't he wants to beat  the case there weren't a lot some of the  videos there's like a lot of people but  it just seemed to be him and a couple  buddies so it didn't seem like he had a  lot of friends maybe he has a more  normal amount of friends like me like he  has a tight tight-knit circle